[Musique]
quand je ramène un verre à la maison
En fait, j'en commande toujours un
Caisse de bière sans alcool avec toi parce que
J'aime le goût de la bière et
Je m'en fiche que ça arrive toujours
Doit contenir de l'alcool
[Musique]
Les bières sans alcool ont donc une longue durée de vie
L'histoire des bières sans alcool est en avance
Il a été inventé en Allemagne il y a 50 ans
à l'époque comme une Audi comme une bière d'automobiliste avec
un groupe cible très clair pour
Des conducteurs qui ne sont pas ivres
Sont autorisés à s'asseoir au volant et cette niche
a la bière sans alcool dans le sens de la longueur
maintenant c'est un style de vie
Le produit est désormais un aliment de luxe
[Musique]
et troisièmement, il y en a bien d'autres
Options comme alcool avec des bières aussi
Vous pouvez réellement goûter le breuvage
tu peux faire ça là où tu as commencé
Par exemple, il y a plus de levure
n'utilisez pas complètement les bières
filtre et la levure est aussi un
Composants de saveur avec lui, vous pouvez
Ce n'est donc pas une tendance à court terme
Cela arrive là où se trouvent de plus en plus de gens
manger plus consciemment, aussi plus consciemment
profiter et boire et en conséquence
Nous en avons même deux maintenant
bières sans alcool
parce que la demande est là aussi
[Musique]